well top covid response officials  including dr anthony fauci held their  first briefing for reporters today  cdcdc director dr rochelle  wallinsky said a new variant of covet 19  first detected in the uk  has now been found in 26 states  including right here in nevada  another variant first identified in  south africa that has shown some  resistance to antibodies  has not been identified stateside dr  anthony fauci said scientists are  working on a booster shot  for the existing vaccines intended to  target the new variant  he said that the vaccines that currently  exist are well within the cushion of  protection  but the variance but added concern about  the future evolution  of the virus